und wir schalten weiter zum bild
kollegen daniel puskepeleitis nach
braunschweig denn dort hatte christian b
auch einen garten mit laube guten morgen
daniel guten morgen was wissen wir dann
über die beziehung von christian b zu
dieser kleingartenanlage in braunschweig
braunschweig war ja die gelebte wohnsitz
von ihm bevor er dann wieder in haft
bekommen ist und er hat hier offenbar im
zeitraum von 2013 bis 2016 eine
gartenlaube im gartenverein kennerblick
und er hatte sich hier offenbar auch
sehr intensiv oder zumindest angepasst
eingefügt in das vereinsleben hat die
daten aber mit erledigt der positive
bescheid nicht als so oft wenn ich
freundlich nur sein
sein abgang hier war wohl etwas
überhastet packte seinen lt voll und
möglicher weg werden denn dort jetzt
auch die bagger anrollen
die staatsanwaltschaft und das bka
hüllen sich in den ermittlungen in
schweigen was tatsächlich die mitglieder
dieser kleingartenkolonie wundert ist
dass die polizei noch nicht da war und
einen blick auf die laube geworfen hat
wie jetzt weiter verpachtet gibt es aber
noch
angeblich wollte man luftaufnahmen
gemacht berichten zeugen aber
durchsuchungen gab es bislang nicht ob
es jetzt natürlich zum tragen kommt ist
derzeit offen